Would oxy cell, oxy cell is a glutathione cream from a company that we don't carry their
products anymore because they won't let us sell them on our store, Apex Energenics?
Would that be something to apply occasionally to the breast area for somebody with breast
cancer?
No, no. So glutathione is not something that we would recommend in general to somebody
with cancer, a period. And if you go to back to our website and you search
harnessing oxidative stress to kill cancer, that will help you understand the process of
trying to not use antioxidants in treating cancer. I know there's differences of opinion in there
in that. I know we have a lot of patients that come to us initially and they went to their
their natural path or their chiropractor and were given a protocol for their cancer and much
of the protocol included high dose antioxidants, alpha-lopeic acid, glutathione products,
glutathione precursors, SOD catalyse. These are all antioxidants. And in the thought process that
well, oxidative stress causes cancer, so we need to decrease oxidative stress. Well,
you haven't listened to me very long. If you haven't heard me talk about the frozen
condoms of oxidative stress with cancer. So as multiple blog posts on glutathione and cancer,
using glutathione with cancer, using oxidative stress,
stimulators to help increase oxidative stress for those with cancer. So I would say, you know,
look at that, look at our website about that. But the answer is quick answer. No, do not do that.